a new week but still a long way to go in
this leadership race
this man still the front runner i'm not
taking anything for granted but no
guarantees in this highly unpredictable
contest
tonight a third round of votes alliance
is shifting in a race still wide open
tom tougandat is eliminated from the
election the other candidates are able
to go forward to a fourth ballot this
man now out that is the end of the road
for me but where next for his backers
tom and the team we will be traveling i
think as a pack
so we will look very closely i think
mostly at the policy areas that pack of
votes could prove crucial in helping
determine the final two candidates but
the right of the party still split in
this round is about moving day for
tomorrow in other words people make
their final decision about who they
really want to take through to the final
round tomorrow kemi badonot put on more
votes than liz trust
a lot of people went to kemi because
they wanted to stop any
now they have to make a decision as to
who they want to vote for the third
round winner here is rishi sunak he is
now just five votes away from making it
into the final two but the real battle
is between penny mordent and liz trust
now as they slug it out for second place
this has become a fight that is as open
and fierce as it is unpleasant and the
real loser in all of it is the
conservative party brand as the johnson
era draws to a close
this a pm determined to go out on a high
pictured here in a typhoon jet enjoying
the perks of the job while he still can
but back down in downing street a dose
of reality how's the temperature sir as
he headed to the commons for a heated
debate and vote of confidence in his
caretaker government
why are they leaving him
with his hands on the levers of power
for eight weeks
eight weeks
where the british public must trust the
word of a prime minister
who's been sacked because he can't be
trusted
the pm fed up and fight him back as he
used one of his final appearances at the
dispatch box to roll out his greatest
hits and get behind whoever comes next
from bishop auckland to barrow we turned
red car blue car we saw 54 seats go
straight from labor to tory and we won
by 80 seats after three dynamic and
exhilarating years
in the cockpit we will find a new leader
and we will coalesce in loyalty around
him or her
but for now there's no love loss between
the various tory camps as candidates
exchange barbs in this ill-tempered
battle for the party leadership still
seven weeks to go it's going to be a
very long summer beth rigby sky news
westminster